the Chinese Communist party has boxed
itself into a dilemma people want an end
to Draconian zero covered restrictions
but easing those restrictions could lead
to a wave of deaths because the country
is simply not prepared kovitzer is
started nearly three years ago in Wuhan
in January 2020. Sky News was there on
the ground there's a bit of confusion as
you might expect given this shutdown
announcement came in the middle of the
night we know the train station the
airport they're both closed we're not
sure about the roads we've seen reports
that they are being blocked by police so
we're going to try and find a way out of
Wuhan
the idea that lockdowns would still be
happening three years later would have
been extraordinary but in the early
stages of the pandemic it worked China's
death rate has been low throughout you
can barely see it on this graph
especially when you compare it to the UK
and the US with a lot more deaths so
zerikovid bought time but China didn't
use it well instead of using it to
vaccinate to improve its medical system
it poured vast resources into testing
like this into lockdowns
it's a bit of a chicken egg
the problem once you're stuck maybe like
China was in this kind of ID that you
could really suppress effectively the
transmission of a virus maybe there was
not this kind of urgency that was needed
to get people vaccinated and think about
the future
as a result China has a very low rate of
elderly vaccination the figure for two
doses aren't bad but only 68 and a half
percent this blue line of people aged
over 60 have received a booster and
that's vital Hong Kong had similarly low
levels of vaccination amongst the
elderly and when Omicron surged out of
control there it recorded the highest
death rate the world had seen now Hong
Kong is interesting for another reason
the population had received a mix of
Western and Chinese vaccine there's been
doubts about the effectiveness of
Chinese vaccines and one study showed
that two doses of Biotech or Pfizer were
much more effective than coronavac the
Chinese vaccine against severe illness
and death but three doses of either
vaccine were just as effective as each
other so the problem isn't the type of
vaccine it's that not enough people had
had it and there's another issue for
China an underdeveloped Health Care
system this is the number of intensive
care beds per person in various
countries and China is all the way down
this league table with just 3.6 beds per
hundred thousand people as a result of
that experts have predicted that an
unchecked spread would simply overwhelm
China's Health Care System there'd be
nearly three million admissions to
intensive care and more than one and a
half million deaths now all of those
problems might be fixed with the
political will but China has trumpeted
its zero covert policy as proof of the
superiority of its system compared to
other countries the problem is that
Chinese people are looking at other
countries and thinking that life there
seems a lot better